angers voilà monsieur bonsoir tout de
suite le cap vers cannes avec une partie
du palmarès est déjà quelques palme pour
le cinéma français un héros très discret
de jacques audois a reçu le prix du
scénario et surtout daniel auteuil le
jeune acteur mongolien pascal duquenne
viennent d'obtenir le prix
d'interprétation masculine depuis nous
retrouvons à cannes bruno alba les
marches les dernières les plus
terrifiantes à celles qui conduisent au
palmarès angoisses de favori pour mike
lee le réalisateur de secrets et
mensonges pour daniel auteuil et pascal
duquenne l'émouvant duo d'acteurs du
huitième jour le film de jaco van
dormael
mais cannes à sa dramaturgie jusqu'à la
dernière minute le secret des
délibérations du jury présidé par
francis ford coppola a été bien gardé
le prix du meilleur scénario pour
jacques audiard est un héros très
discret et un double prix
d'interprétation pour daniel auteuil et
pascal duquesne dans aucun pour le film
de jaco van dormael
l'émotion du public de ce 49e festival
de cannes
bouleversé par la projection du huitième
jour le film de jaco van dormael
encouragements de daniel auteuil pour
son jeune partenaire
nul ne saurait dire lequel des deux est
fait tout à l'heure le plus ému